toute l'année les jeunes se sont
mobilisés pour le climat et cet été
certains d'entre eux qu'on se rendre
dans des festivals de musique
alors moi je vous pose une question est
ce que vraiment c'est écologique les
festivals de musique et est ce que les
organisateurs de ces événements font des
efforts pour protéger le climat est bien
pour avoir la réponse j'ai décidé
d'aller interviewer les organisateurs
des différents festivals
[Musique]
par exemple cette année pour la première
fois on va collecter et recycler
spécifiquement les mégots on aura deux
hommes qui sera une arme à alimenter en
énergie avec des matériels qui lui même
est alimenté grâce à des panneaux
photovoltaïques
[Musique]
une des grosses parties de déchets en
plaine du festival c'est la restauration
nous on a des restaurateurs qui sont
tous indépendants qui fonctionne
différemment et c est justement ce qui
fait vaisselle etc
c'est eux qu'ils fournissent et du coup
on peut pas forcément les convaincre
facilement je sais que d'autres
festivals arrive à le faire de partir
dans la sueur du tout propos stable ou
du thouraud cyclable du tout carton etc
alors honnêtement pas ce jour ça c'est
voilà c'est un travail de
sensibilisation qu'il faudrait qu'il
faudra probablement un jour qu'on mène
avec avec les restaurateurs pour
basculer petit à petit sur des déchets
qui peuvent êtres qui peuvent être
recyclés
après cette interview je suis bien
curieux de savoir comment ça se passe
dans le festival le plus sale que j'ai
jamais essayé tout simplement c'est le
festival de dour en belgique et donc je
vais me rendre et il peut arriver
les organisateurs d'un festival mondial
donc on a des festivaliers qui viennent
un peu de partout et donc on sait que la
problématique du tri des déchets est
très compliqué donc cette année ce qu'on
a fait ce qu'on fait un projet pilote
on a demandé à tous nos partenaires de
réaliser des gobelets en pp et c'est une
matière bien précises qui rentre dans le
tri et donc ce qui permet que maintenant
sur le festival
on n'a plus que deux sortes de tri et +3
donc cpmc plus donc ce sont toutes les
matières plastiques et le reste est tout
venant sur le terrain le triplé facile
on a beaucoup de gobelets de pmc très
peu de tout venant mais le problème sur
les campings c'est tout ce dont les
festivaliers prennent et ne repartent
pas avec le camping corps était
malheureusement je pense
qu'effectivement on aura vous pouvez
regarder lundi ce sera encore
malheureusement très sale et pour savoir
pourquoi ses six salles et comment
pallier ce problème
j'ai discuté avec sylvie dénonçant la
présidente de la sbl 3d chargé du
ramassage et du tri fait il ya des
festivaliers qui partent en laissant
absolument tous leurs déchets des tanks
des boîtes de conserve
les matelas les sacs de couchage on a
vraiment une grosse grosse prise de
conscience depuis quelques années les
festivaliers viennent demander leurs
sacs poubelles ou distribuer un sac bleu
donc sac pmc et un sac noir aux
festivaliers et on a organisé ça c'est
une nouveauté de l'année un service de
ramassage dans le camping donc vous avez
vous pouvez poser votre petit sac
poubelle à l'entrée de votre tante et
vous avez une petite voiturette qui y
passent devant qui ramassent votre sac
poubelle et l'embarquent vers le parc à
conteneurs
on est quand même arrivé à créer cette
fameuse chaîne de tri justement pour
vraiment avoir un trick parfait pour
vraiment voir mon cycle et le maximum de
nos déchets sachant qu effectivement si
on a une poubelle qui est pollué par un
déchet qu'il n'est pas approprié
c'est tout le sac poubelle qui peut être
déclassé donc c'est un peu dommage de
devoir incinérés des matériaux qui
peuvent être recyclés
nous sommes les poubelles de tous les
sites et du campus
et de l'entrée oui ferrand tri avec
et
soit beaucoup le matin parce qu'il ya
toutes les poubelles de la veille et
alors pour les soirs on est il
ici on les amène là bas laon
les déversent on mais par goût
et après on se mêle
de la chaîne et
tout ce qui est en c1
et là
[Applaudissements]
d'autres festivals ont carrément fait du
développement durable leur credo et
apparemment on a tout à y gagner
le pour nous le développement durable
c'est pas vécu comme une contrainte mais
c'est plutôt vécu comme une opportunité
d'améliorer le confort de nos
festivaliers nos équipes
[Musique]
car ça nous oblige à réfléchir sur plein
de choses sur comment mieux se nourrir
comment mieux se déplacer comment mieux
construire mieux acheter
bref ça nous oblige à avoir des
comportements responsables donc c'est
plus de travail mais au final c'est je
pense une vraie plus value pour le
festival
[Musique]